[Music]
Hey hello everyone I am live welcome
I'm just doing my quick setup stuff
popping all my chats out and that I've
got it
hihihihihi act1 everyone else was
already allowed to livestream today we
have streaming act 2 for the guy who
does Austin YouTube chat because nobody
else does really what I'm gonna do that
before today Tuesday was the embargo so
I just wanted to show you guys some
footage a little further through the
game I chose not to go too far towards
the end so I'm also not spoiling it but
yeah it's just like kind of a meteor
area of the game at this point so
streaming hello everyone
please note I'm really bad at
platformers I say that on this channel
all the time I've never been shy about
it I'm terrible at them so accept me for
who I am it's like one genre I am
atrocious at okay I think I did all that
right yeah yeah good yeah yeah yeah I
think we're all good it's a very good
game very very very good game
have I seen Castlevania I have not
I've type fast that comes with being a
journalist you have to type things as
you're hearing them a lot of the time
and it's not easy to do so
yeah use a practice there alrighty
you don't have to play the first one
Bobby that is totally not a thing that
you have to do I would recommend it
because it's very good but you don't
have to do it I do not wear hair
extensions ever Jesse this is my real
hair 100% real it's just very long all
right what are we doing here that's
right
yes normal
and the Instagram that do
[Music]
uh-huh and one day I'll do this stuff
before I go live but today is not that
day
mm-hmm mm-hmm
cube home sighs chair alone is odd
that's me
I always misspell my own username
because it is a bunch of [ __ ] less
so yes hello welcome everyone we're
playing Ori
it's a beautiful video game for anyone
who doesn't know which I guess you
probably wouldn't because I don't really
talk about this side of things at every
outlet where I've had to give review
schools which I've not had to do it
inside gaming I didn't have to do it so
in the previous companies that I've
worked at but every outlet I have given
review schools to my two highest scores
were minecraft which was actually the
the AA version of Minecraft that I
scored specifically I think I may have
also done the switch review and Far Cry
3 and both of those were a 9.5 naturally
I have not reviewed every video game but
I would also give re o Hallel T to
assign light posts what is that
do I have light bursts I don't appear to
have light bursts my dude I guess it
wants me to light that on fires what
it's telling me yeah yeah if I if I if
it were a thing I would have given this
game a 9.5 it's fantastic I love it
Thank You Louie I appreciate that
Jackson I probably maybe will leave the
vault they vote up for this one for the
first time ever it's not the thing and I
tend to do a lot of what is light bus so
use it to light torches light bursts I
don't seem to have that yet so I got I
cannot do I need to go buy it now
perhaps
am I just stuck in this room yeah I'm
doing that exit okay let's go have a
outplayed Okami a show have a show I
have
how are my hands they're getting better
if they really are thank you um okay is
this a thing that you're gonna tell me I
need to buy from someone maybe we're not
ready to be here yet no that seems right
so yeah here's the map it big it pretty
I could go out here that's a sidequest
that's sort of main but only ish
rebuilding glades I do that all the time
I really didn't explore a lot of this
stuff I could have done more that's he
lost in Paradise find the strength of
the forest that sounds like a main quest
find it we're trying to strength to the
land let's do that
you just go that way because whatever
I'm trying to do now is get to the
highest peak I don't feel like I'm ready
to do that ting so we're not gonna do it
so yeah um this game I will say because
you will notice it even though Xbox did
give me this code and they suggested
that I play it on Xbox one X which is
exactly what I'm playing it on this game
does have framerate issues it's a huge
bummer the first like maybe three out oh
that's where it is I got the filthy high
needed from the tree let's go back then
the first like three hours I didn't have
so many problems but it became pretty
clear afterwards that there are a lot of
framerate drops it's a huge bummer
because otherwise it's just such a
stunning game and it's so sharp and
smooth and the gameplay is just so
satisfying
so yeah big ol bum of it that's what we
want we're gonna replace my bun very
cool
I love a good mysterious seed yeah the
music is beautiful how is the audio you
guys can you can you hear it well what
are you talking about my income
sometimes in order to displace games
some money but doesn't care about games
as much as she suggests that's so cute
yeah all that money I make playing game
since I was what three years old and
knowing more about them than pretty much
any human you know try me but you know
I'm a woman but yes you will notice
framerate drops I just didn't want to
that's gonna be why I did want to point
that out from the very beginning that
that is not a problem with my machine
because people gonna be like what's
wrong is it a stream problem alas it is
not use - on charge like bursts charge
okay so you probably want me to go up
there so that's a - we're gonna yeah I
see I see we're gonna break all of this
- that's right wait wait hang on hang on
can I use the light bus myself and then
I can - my own light beam that whoa the
sentence I just said is not gonna make
sense to anyone who hasn't played this
game it's quite quite complex I don't
know why I keep doing it like it's not
gonna regenerate forever I do not have a
discard server
I do not it's interesting that they say
the PC version is the most stable one so
far
yeah you really do want me to send my
own one up okay so we're going why and
then I don't know why we want it we're
gonna send it right up and we're gonna
why oh it comes back and then we want to
bash my own I'm unclear on this
okay I can charge it that's the charge
and then we're gonna they're gonna haha
I see very cool so I now have my own
ability that I can bash Rome which is
this game is fantastic
well now I probably can go up this way
what are you leading me to that's gonna
take me to top of the tree okay
aha there's a platform it's up there
yeah a lot of this game is just about
discovery like figuring out where things
are like on the map you like well I know
I have to get there but I don't know how
to get there and yeah the puzzles for
that are really fun okay this is gonna
be a little bit tricky it's gonna be a
little bit tricky you beat it a couple
of weeks ago Kenneth that's strange
we only got codes on Friday do you mean
the plain forest uh yeah this game is
only put in anyone's hands very Oh
[ __ ] press the wrong button because I
wasn't paying attention
putting anyone's hands super recently so
I don't know how you would have done
that excuse me sir I will take you
please thank you charge that bash it
bash it actually I'm gonna make already
stick again we turned that off what do
we got orbs mid splinter I'm gonna swap
that out and I'm gonna put sticky Ori
back on that's this one make him stick
okay I think we're gonna need to do a
charge bash here which is gonna be tough
yeah maybe not maybe I'm wrong it does
seem like it wants me to go higher from
here right okay I'm just gonna go back
this way to make sure that's what I'm
supposed to be doing there's a lot of it
yeah there's a lot of stuff in this game
that I'll be like surely it doesn't want
me to do that and then it turns out that
it totally does and it happens in the
most beautiful way possible it's very
very impressive yeah it does want me to
do that okay I don't want to do it but I
will if you demand that I to
angle it so it comes down at the right
time correct
that is how bash works but even then
it's mostly just hitting projectiles
when you can jump it on up I'm just not
positive there's a platform over here
and there's no way for me to see but
let's let's shoot it up and then just
hit it on the way down and see if it
works
Wow mmm that is what I want it's just a
collectible no that's not where I have
to progress I think I can do it this
gonna be tough one though it's just a
bummer that I fold the whole way down
okay I'm gonna do this it's not like
have to be very precise with it it's
fine this is gonna be tough it's gonna
be tough
that's probably about right yeah not as
tough as I expected I love me some or
okay I think that's as far as I can go
correct confirm for me map it confirmed
okay
where do we want to go from here just go
back that's it
we just gone back grab this so if you
couldn't tell this game is absolutely
stunning beautiful school like I think I
mentioned if you want me to UM change
the mix if you guys are having trouble
hearing it or anything let me know that
I could do that real quick nice work but
it should be fine not be good um and
yeah this is Zack - it's about four
hours in these guys are tough real tough
I thought that I changed it to my my -
rude very rude okay see another frame
rate drop there it's always such a bond
my hey talk characters in this game are
really good in a way that I find like
very much like breath of the wild
they're just really sweet very nice like
I don't know they're uh sweet nice it
dumb words to use but they're also just
really creative though the design is
really interesting they speak in in
different ways yeah this portion of the
game is like just off of meeting the
character who's basically this game's
like big bad guy the framerate drops
right now are really bad I swear they
usually not oh this bad you're dead mate
you're dead okay so now I can find stuff
changes everything
hello yeah this auto-saves everywhere
but you can save the game with these
little shrine things too which is very
nice very nice Jim Gettys said there was
a pot that was a mix of breath the wild
and Pixar I would guess he's talking
about the intro I think I'm supposed to
do this yet how about any of that I can
get through here somehow but my guess is
that opens from the other side at a
later point and we ain't ready to do
that yet now I can fast travel from the
other where am I going
why to warp I think I want to go over
here so we're probably gonna get there
from here who knows let's find out
could anyone describe the plot of this
this game to you Kevin um well it's
about a little a little spirit named Ori
there's a cute little family that he
wants to protect from all the bad things
that happen in the forest that's the
simplest way to describe it and I don't
think the plot is the ploys is very
sweet and thoughtfully crafted but I
don't think the plot is the reason you
play this game that the combat is just
very very good sorry big gameplay talk
to stream and talk at the same time
skill I have not mastered this Punk I
don't know if I want to be [ __ ] with
that okay so we're just going like far
to the left right and jumping back
around that way yeah pretty much
you know I thought I would stick to that
just fine
hey but hey rude all right we're gonna
done this before
there was spikes there everything's fine
I really like the use of the UM motion
blur and a lot of these segments why you
put that fat mate this seems like a
place I would come to die sand okay
well we don't need to go that way that's
cool you don't need to tell me twice
alright but let's do it
but up up I can't attack on the water
I'm just I'm that right there we go okay
come on come on I missed it don't die
don't die a little re just get it just
get it it's too it's too far away there
we go jerks um yeah I talk to myself a
lot while I play this game oh you don't
know you don't I don't have time for
that I think because I feel personally
responsible when anything bad happens to
re that's why I talk to myself so much
oh you drowned but you drowned it was a
new bag attention can't confer music is
beautiful
it's very good
gripped I'm very bad at platformers that
said I'm actually not that bad at Ori
because it's um I don't know just the
fluidity of it as swim right into it
it's why why mine in a book that's the
we're gonna drown again but it's fine
let me just figure out where I'm
navigating to nope okay so it's gonna be
up in to the right very quickly
nobody hit me I'm small and I am fragile
and I do not have time [ __ ] immediately
get out of here get I'm - I'm too tiny
I have business to attend to the forest
needs me if anyone sees an air pocket
please let me know no can I use these is
there no we'll get there unless there's
a bubble that I am missing somewhere oh
that's it let's see how about right
there literally right there all right
no you don't know you don't know we just
get it on this end that's it yeah you're
supposed to pay attention okay so I
guess like in this save I would have
unlocked the ability to swim like this
by cleaning out the water maybe I only
like an hour or so ago pretty recent
thing is framerate
ish come on mate get it together
where previously yeah all the water was
poisoned so I couldn't even interact
with it just the map is just the most
Metroidvania thing ever so it's all just
hey I didn't realize you were alive it's
all just unfolding before my eyes okay
you'll probably leave all that we need
to figure out how to get over this way
how am I gonna climb this
mmm no it's gonna have to go to the
right gonna have to go to the right
maybe this wheel do something I can't
use any abilities underwater yet so I
can't I can't be strong with that but
yeah this game is a lot of puzzles too
just a lot of very big very sweet
puzzles well why'd that happen
I'm just gonna shoot at that because why
not we're just gonna be blowing that up
all right P buddy sorry you were minding
your own business and I have to take you
out like that what we got to do what we
got to do well this is just rude who set
this up
I thought if I hit your stock it
wouldn't be a problem but it was what is
wrong with the frame rate here this is
like absolutely the worst it's ever been
okay we're gonna have to use I reckon
I'd have to charge it it's complicated
it's complicated stuff it's complicated
stuff oh it's bad why is it so bad I
don't know maybe get some waters causing
problems and maybe it's just the motion
blurs is confusing me but use it's a
very good game stuff I can't confirm it
is a wonderful game let's do this it
didn't even charge really at all
not even close
that's gotta be it there's no way other
there's no other way I can get up there
I just just it looks like it's operating
in slow motion because of the [ __ ]
blow I can't get through this which
sucks
still no underwater abilities yeah I
know I love me I'm holding me like is it
just that I'm in water cuz I feel like
it's more than that we're just gonna
swim up I'm gonna tap a twice and then
we're gonna work oh I'm out of out of
out of spirit I can't use it anymore
okay I'm heading back don't don't don't
don't even don't leave me alone leave me
alone Chuck I'm just a little far spirit
minding my own business and maybe
drowning to death again it is brutal to
look at okay I guess we're going up
I do need some crystals though yeah I
can probably just make that run but it's
just by surprise I'll be instead of LV
okay at least we get some hey what it's
not where I left off
that's rude we're gonna come on come on
buddy
come on come on it's not not a good time
it's goddamn framerate okay hey that's
better
all right little Rd let's just get you
up over here everything will be a-okay
um that makes sense
avoid the spikes and we did it alright
story question mark
sometimes your little wisps talk to you
does have very good use of um depth with
the FPS thinks it does in part not
consistently I know I'm trying don't all
right get on me I'm moving very quickly
frankly my speeds are unmatched like one
drink there's like a setting problem
this looks so bad in this area like that
framerate is not how this game generally
looks I don't know what's happened
alright sure I'll take you okay that's
just rude I had no way of knowing that
was gonna happen that's rude just mean
okay come on go for it come on
it's gonna be hard because the last time
I did this like very much cheated okay
the last time I did it I waited for them
to fall and I think they came back up
maybe I get an under what a - that I
just don't have yet that it won't cuz
like you can trigger it right
it's rigor it I'm just killing this
young man trigger it and then you swim
out of the way and then you swim back
over the top no I didn't make it through
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to do
that yeah the last one I did was it in
the air it's probably something I need
but house we're gonna get up here we're
gonna use out - again probably
missed it come on bud come on bud you
got it
there we go hey what's that mochi these
are the luma pulse that is where I am at
the bubble won't get you up I don't
believe shouldn't be allowed to steal
small clumps like that yeah they do like
that's that's the biggest thing that I
want to note to people about this game
is that it looks a certain way that
people would get the impression that
it's child is so easy maybe but this is
very much a challenging platformer it's
um the gameplay is very very very good
and it would be a huge bummer if anyone
was off quit by it looking beautiful and
indie for some reason when yeah it's
it's absolutely tough and and just
really well designed in terms of
mechanics okay I'm not gonna do any of
that business yet nope okay going down
again then I guess sometimes you see it
up up up only way to go whoa whoa oh
okay okay I didn't even see that coming
there's some kind of gust here was it
there the whole time where did you come
from and why have you done this to me
that ghost wasn't there the whole time
right
hmm that's curious
hmm hmm an interesting conundrum happens
if I light a bubble on fire oh sorry but
didn't mean to do that
that's my be all right I'm gonna just go
up okay I can't keep going hi about the
looks of things so let's just do that
keep going up it's always a safe bet
right should I go on the outside on the
inside let's try the outside first I
guess
mm I can pro well okay we want that
collectible so I'm gonna jump back in
there anyway for the record
ghosts kill I really only talked to
myself while playing video games while
I'm streaming I guess I do a little bit
like I said I talk to Orion this game
will be like oh I'm sorry buddy if I
kill him or whatever for the most part
not a thing I do all the time is it
coming switched on day one day one is
today the public can play this game in
about half an hour so Oh got a business
email sorry about that
yeah um yeah I don't I don't think it's
on switch today okay we're gonna go back
for the other one yeah this game is full
of collectibles oh no it's gonna need to
come back to me so we're gonna just have
to feel like this slightly I love yep
too fast just a little bit above like
right like again give me more shards
there was some like right near here
right there we go yes please let me
restock on those I don't know how
quickly they respawn is it when I move
out of frame nope come back buddy you
know you want to you can't just wait on
it I guess
try again it's gotta be directly above
me
unfortunately it's supposed to fall okay
I need you to fall stop hitting it just
trying to get it to like loop over a
little bit so that I won't completely
lose it but that's probably not gonna
work it's great that one up
I just need to it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be fling myself it's gonna be
agree it's gonna be a challenge is what
I'm gonna say don't do that and then oh
we took the hell sometimes you got to
take a hit to get that good good soul
money which I should be spending a lot
more of frankly
all righty little guy up you go huh
the soundtrack so good it's so pretty
[Music]
why is EI q canceling that's dollars
games good question I think it's because
they're making enough money off their
mobile stall those games they don't give
a [ __ ] about the rest of it in part at
least it's fine if we get hit in order
to get up I don't care
Ari's pretty squishy what is wrong with
the framerate right now god I promise
this game doesn't normally look this bad
like it definitely has drops frequently
but not like this wonder if there's
anything else along here no okay let's
go oh it's just chugging
I'm just gonna see what's up to top
nothing probably statistically something
weighs everything up here got so many um
goddamn thorns on it though like who
designed this hellscape not missed it
alright fine get out of here crab or
whatever you are okay that do something
helpful I don't think so
probably drop down through this it's
probably a secret down here I can bash
myself got it
I was hitting it so that's a bit rude
I'm gonna need you to do that again
please excuse me
all righty but and we have to hit him
there to blow that up okay yeah
not sure why I just did that did I need
that to be open don't think so okay
another tough one we're gonna hit some
spikes you're probably gonna die
probably gonna die William the framerate
cannot drop by virtue of my streaming at
the same time I'm playing on xbox
completely separate console but
naturally does not know that I am
streaming it's just that the game has
it's um has its problems a Gilley's 10
said Ilana did you play through the
blind forest I played it but didn't
finish it which you know happens
sometimes this isn't gonna work it's not
gonna come back is just gonna hit the
ceiling so we can't rely on that here
hmm wonder if there's something else to
be oh I can balance okay I don't need to
right now though can we blow this up
maybe give me another
give me another enemy you just poop that
out all right I'm am I gonna hit you
over there I think I probably screwed up
the aim there try again what boom
success negative needs to be purple
alright well this looks like a nightmare
so that's fun I'm gonna bounce I'm gonna
land in the spikes I was trying to hit
that bit of ceiling what does the map
look like like a by map not be handy we
do have to go up there somehow I could
go from the other direction that's right
no hit it again
come on oh this is so hard to play with
this framerate
gosh dang having it oh it's so bad
what's happened to you very hard to do
things with precision when you can't see
all right Ori all right
just shoot it up but don't hit anything
that's all I'm asking you to do okay all
righty okay that's easy
didn't I find that forever ago what are
you just telling me now great love it
I'm out of [ __ ] spirit again okay oh
my god I can't believe how about this is
this is nuts maybe this area is just
terrible attacks that shouldn't be a
problem in a single-player game
I don't imagine that's the issue my
guess is that this is the first area
open and it's like a ton of water to
this extent my guess is that that's what
the game is having trouble with but who
knows
like ya know - it shouldn't like in
theory it's connected to service but I
can't imagine because people aren't
playing on a server I kind of imagine
that would be causing any framerate
drops we're not honest oh thanks for
letting me know for some reason I guess
I needed to know that this one first
shall we yeah cool
can I activate underwater shrine
apparently not I'm gonna need to drain
this then I guess air please thank you
okay so you go - what's that close that
huh
this is so pretty I can't do it too slow
all right it's okay
oh come on but come on but come on bad
thing ah so close so close
let me find something to - on is my next
guest I am holding a son we're doing at
that whole time no I can't see anything
in the water - to bash on come on come
on Laurie oh if there were fish down
here I would think that that would be it
but they ain't no fish good good oxygen
alright yeah I can always go back to it
it's fine
morgue or like or
where is sympathy or for simpleton
YouTube chat
I'm pretty sure it is I'm pretty sure
that's what a simple Oh the mixer chat
just uploaded or updated a lot red
rubber said did you are any the fun
house gameplay was on today what did you
search they think if so we did not play
was on we actually played already today
so we'll have am a video got up soon
probably by the end of the week
hopefully I don't know we'll see
Bruce was really our uh Battle Royale
guy it's not what's seen without him you
know it's like cheating how can I use my
yeah disability no ma'am cannot blow of
a giant rocks with a tiny feather who'd
have thought who'd have thought
okay Thank You Bowen uh-huh
that's the best Deadly Premonition very
good game okay so what just happens if I
just do this way no that's never gonna
work unless that one just stays open for
longer maybe it could do right right it
does stay open for a long time let's try
it I don't like my chances but we'll try
it keep going but keep going oh that was
it I never would have guessed
I really never would have guessed that
it was just that you have to do it in
the opposite order to what you would
think you do it in wait what's happening
right now is it losing water or gaining
water I think a new area is gaining
water is what just happened to you which
should mean that this is draining but it
doesn't appear to be draining hey that
was unnecessary hit me right in my face
call me a 10 son you want to try me
we're gonna put you right there
fame fame baby yes please thank you
Ultra bash you say I'm gonna be taking
that no maybe I should where is it Ultra
bash bash deals damage yeah no I don't
need that kind of nonsense in my life
okay
nowhere to go we did it all all right
little bud oh it did drain up here got
it okay cool
I will take that
you got timed out on twitch at I don't
know why that would happen
listen I don't care about the cheese guy
let him talk about his cheese you know
twitch chat if he wants to talk about
cheese it's cool with me cool with me
soundtrack is really good
[Music]
okay no give me map I use the map a lot
in this game it's very well designed
there's some game sir I'm like I'm
[ __ ] with that map that's useless
garbage
okay there's nothing to go that way it
still wants me to go up from here I
don't know why I didn't there was a
reason I didn't correct
hey cutie
I think I already spoke to you about
like fish or something oh okay I don't
think I have a string or a net my sweet
friend it seems so much suspicious why
is that there
okay I don't remember why it didn't let
me go up here so I'm just doing it again
I guess nope nope land lower you idiot
you beautiful idiot
[Music]
I still have this piece of [ __ ]
stupid weapon swap that out get rid of
that garbage oh I would like that life
shot a whole lot okay am i higher than I
was
yes sir what's here
hmm what's up with you up there what
have you been up to lately mom what'd
you do with your spare time thank you
yeah I feel like this will change when I
drain the water is probably what
happened seems like a thing okay we want
to get up there we're just gonna have to
jump it no but I don't have anything to
break that with you little tease you
little tease hmm is this the highest
part of this we have reached the cap I
should be able to get through this
though but I guess I'm gonna have to do
that from the other side
yep it's not happening today it's not
happening for me uh Logan I'm about five
hours into the game what's my favorite
cheese I really like brie Brie is
probably my favorite cheese it's very
good
welcome back scoot away all right so to
open that thing I need an enemy to bash
against there on on seems suspicious but
it's fine
cool cool love that for me I would like
to know what's up with this flower up
here if I'm being honest I would like to
know what your deal is that's that's
great okay what did it just do nothing
yeah I'm not gonna be able to get that
way I gotta go back here back down all
right
mmm-hmm can the super bash maybe
actually break those things now I don't
think it can I just don't see it
happening you know we can't bash on a
mm-hmm-hmm
that's to see it's not gonna work I just
know it's not gonna work maybe maybe
that's what it is maybe I need to equip
super bash sounds like Super Bass like
the Nicki Minaj song but it ain't ultra
bash sorry I'm getting over in a magnet
I'm gonna equip Ultra bash gonna give it
a shot
we are going to how's this gonna work
how's this gonna work do that and then
that made it too far
I'm going to attempt to get why boom and
then LT no okay I just want to test if
this leave and walk okay we go why not
again
son of a-- excuse me I need you thank
you hey well that's just mean I maybe
there's something I need you down here
now this game sure is a puzzle like this
dumb face looking a big dumb face you're
adorable
I definitely can't get up that top area
I can find that there are two pathways
here I've done everything here
the framerate dough is so bad no I have
you done that to mean to do that
you haven't figured out how to get rid
of those so those went underwater
shootout enemies is is that the problem
do it can I get the water back maybe
because I would be able to break that
other I don't even see that that
framerate was so that I'd be able to
break that other contraption if the
water came back which had a lever
somewhere I don't remember where it was
get out of here
I think I did this the other way around
last time didn't I
pepper jack is a good cheese it's gonna
seem very weird to anyone who's just
watching this and doesn't have the
context of the church did the chitchat
the twitch chat is talking about cheese
can I go down here No
we're going back up I guess Hayley get
out of here we just keep losing the
shards please come to me thank you thank
you
all righty
trying to get it to flip me up this way
yeah um nope nope didn't need to do that
had already been here okay
this is literally all done I don't know
why that level was there that's probably
what I need to figure out the lever that
took the water away I need the water
back please bring the water back I can't
do it without you water
I would love to chat to this man right
now that would be very handy he would
give me a map that would be a great time
loves a good map this is the new area
that opened up which makes me think that
I should be down here I did already
break most of this can I just get you to
follow me for a really long time how far
you willing to follow me dude
that might work oh we need water we're
gonna die we're gonna die we're gonna
Ori no re not now dammit
it was now my second all my spirits back
to I didn't it just restarted okay give
me that good oxygen thank you okay I'm
gonna see if I can get this stupid fish
to follow me for a really long time I
can that's it
and we need to fling you up into the air
did it work
it did thanks for your help I hope you
enjoyed being able on for the first time
in your life seems like that was
probably a chill time
I was dramatic why was that so dramatic
one time few crab not today
all right crabs just appearing out of
out of wood I see I see how it is not
you too no I don't have spirit icon i'm
walked in here that's what's gonna
happen this is oh they have these little
combat arenas every now and then not
commonly i mean that's gonna be come on
give me a shot yeah by the way
damn it come on come on okay babe
dead not you again I just don't have
time I'm just here trying to you know
save my friends or whatever I'm not
really sure just bouncing off stuff
doing spirit things it'd be cool if this
game had some kind of parry I'm in the
beginning I would dig that it's not alas
it does not oh that was wobbly just cos
everything again cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo
tight tight tight tight tight
is there anything up there is let's go
up nope that's gonna stay closed don't
open it for nobody
alright
I just like to go up first you know oh
that's you want that give me that
oh cool this is like gonna be one of
those time trial things someone's not
activated right now though that's Jill
that's Jill down we go great brilliant
love it
big fan all right I need somebody to
attack me
anyone it's not you can't just be doing
that to people it's so rude that's not
nice
all right okay
just give me a heads up before you stomp
my body with a giant rock come on not
today
oh oh I saw that I want that you give me
I'm gonna drown I'm gonna drown again
it's great I love it I love it I love it
okay but I see what you were hiding now
so and I'm coming to take it from you
what you gonna do about it
all right we got the rock we get the
rock out we steal the rock [ __ ] we run
away take that Dwayne Johnson and then
we go up for this air pocket this is
gonna kill me oh thank god
risky business right there all right
okay excuse me yes I need you in several
locations but first right here where are
you work this way
aha done yeah okay well now my YouTube
chat is also talking about cheese so
that's great
you are right I did ask to be attacked
not by what but I got what I wanted it's
fine
sometimes you need someone to attack you
to be able to progress in life these
lessons in mall with Orion the blind no
Will O the wisps who are you what are
you doing down here
cool cool cool we're not prepared for
this we're going to drown again you know
the strategy Ilana you prefer up so
always start with up hey it's my mate I
it's good to see you too mmm been maybe
like an Iowa since you left your hollow
very recent see how good the characters
design in this game is though it's
beautiful how do I like the game so far
oh gee King off oh it's incredible this
game is beautiful
okay we just go in for swims now with my
giant frog friend I sure hope so he's
like the coolest guy I know I should I
should be looking for them at this point
I should know that they're there but I
don't I don't
okay let's we're gonna go the air
version because I don't want to deal
with any of you [ __ ] all right now it's
just a seed dammit
I was hoping that you would be my way
out of the water there is a way up that
one we couldn't get because there were
people walking it this is all the map
isn't covered so far by the way for time
reference since the stream started we
moved from about here to across here so
that's however long that took how long
is that ticket tell me how long that is
taken roughly an L okay so it's pretty
big okay let's just see if there is more
up right here or if I gotta go somewhere
else for the up up to go okay okay I see
you
damnit out of it okay hi
you're joke and I hate you
I think I decided I was not prepared for
this area for some reason and I really
missed that cuz I need someone to attack
me and I don't had it have anyone know
that's why how do I get past them fast
enough though I actually don't know how
to do it I am holding a to swim faster
it's a thing that I do constantly
because I don't know why you wouldn't do
that in this game
at all times all right mate go for it go
for it go for it go on go on
boo no Matt we're just gonna we're gonna
drown is there any way for me to swim
way FASTA you don't think so
how to avoid giant crushy block that
grinds my brittle body to a meat
um you can use Lydian Muse I'm sorry I
don't know say anything he said can you
trip the first what go above it and trip
the next and then repeat to the third
walk you can trip every block but trust
me doing three in a row is so much
harder than you would think underwater
because it's too slow frankly I've never
done it like I I it is physically
possible but watch watch what's gonna
happen here like cuz this is so slow
is that every single one is the physics
of it are possible I don't think it's
actually possible but I guess that's the
only thing I can think of to try right
now in any case so we will try unless I
can just go right above it like maybe
that's an entrance to something I don't
think it's gonna walk well it's my
supposed to do is there anywhere else to
go alright let's try up again
oh I can land on that that's a better
idea
oh I'm supposed to hit that he was
supposed to get it re now you're on a
spiritual again you little jerk okay
just try that from here you're supposed
to that you can connect to that but come
on you know how to do it does that hit
me like a wall no okay down jump maybe
maybe maybe yeah so close give it
another shot I do really like that
because because of the way the physics
in this game work there are a lot of
things that you would think of possible
that like often I'm like surely that's
not the solution but it works and
sometimes I do wonder if there oh I just
pressed her own button multiple
solutions to every problem because of
how creative it feels like you get with
the environments I just don't know if
everything that I'm doing is what it's
designed to do okay that's not what we
wanted at all just go here so what I'm
trying to do is drop jump back and then
I'm gonna need to drop jump jump it's
gonna be tough I don't I don't know that
this is is the option
finally I had my shots that might be
very handy did I come through this way I
think I did right wait why am I not
picking those up is it cuz I already did
it yes I have been over that way okay
I'm gonna try that one more time but I
think it's probably not the correct
thing to do or if I have my spirit shots
it would be a lot easier at least come
on bud okay let's just go slightly under
and oh oh so close yeah jump back up
come on [ __ ]
so one would hope the dopes that have
multiple solutions like I man that's not
really how most games work frankly most
puzzles don't have have multiple
solutions because it's really hard to
like its program for that but if it does
I don't know if that's what it wants me
to do but again without this ability I
cannot do anything we're gonna give this
another shot
see what happens 100th time is the
Chandler's wanted to see if maybe there
was something up there go through here
no all right you jerk come on it's just
not gonna be possible unless I'm never
gonna be able to swim faster wait I'm
just gonna try and straight shot it cuz
maybe they're a lot slower into water
than I think they are but I don't think
it's gonna work get out of here I could
have that projectile following me the
whole way that would be tight all right
come on bud well you got caught on the
call night I just can't see it working I
just can't see it working you know it
just can't see it happening um I'm gonna
see if I can find a sneaky way to swim
around it that I'm not noticing right
now
can i well that did work but then this
one's just gonna that worked for a
second I don't know how though I'm not
sure what I did come on but you got it
you got it
speed is never going to work
definition of insanity etc etc it's
gonna be a way to trick it if I could
get that thing to follow me the whole
way I could like do you attack me maybe
do you shoot something at me please
I don't know friends I don't know yeah
triggering each block before going
through he's not gonna work
my name is not Daniel it is not going to
work fake it and go from top like I said
that's what I've been trying to do I can
show you guys what that looks like but
it's too slow orys recovery from like
triggering to swimming back up he's wait
I just punch my microphone sorry that
was very loud he's way too slow I just
don't see it happening he doesn't jump
back around fast enough so we trigger it
trigger it and then try to swing back
over that's just gonna happen every time
he's too slow too slow
I cannot boost and shoot across I do not
have any abilities underwater
stay down what you just want me to try
on the very bottom I'm just gonna get
smushed I'm just gonna get killed that's
the only ability I have underwater FYI
but that is only when there's a
projectile shot at me okay if I just
stay low I'm also just going to get
smushed it don't work that way the one
thing that might get me is if I can find
something to follow me the whole way
there but it's a long trick
are there any fish here who would like
to assist me okay let's see if we can
get this guy again huh Hey open why
would you open oh no that's not that's
supposed to work
I was right there come on now come on
now maybe because I already did it it's
not letting me do it again
I knew I would do that but okay come on
hey they're just not just not working
now if I could get that fish I think all
my problems would be solved but I can't
get the fish anything I'm missing from
the old game no they're actually um very
similar okay so okay you're all telling
me to bait it low and then go back under
I just don't think he's ever gonna be
fast enough to do that three times I'll
give it a shot
fade it low go back under just good gets
cold on the edge I just don't I just
don't see it happening for all three
blocks if it was just one I think I've
done that before but you really don't
control very well in the water and you
get stuck obviously trying to get back
out because it's so slow
okay I'm gonna die of lack of oxygen -
right before I could do that three times
because there are no air bubbles this
whole way either which is it seems weird
can I get that air bubble no that's fake
okay now we're definitely going to drown
okay so if I do that then wait for it
and then go and then do that again I'll
see it walk in y'all I don't see it
working
[Music]
I tried made any under and swimming
above my guess here is just that there's
a there's a underwater - that I need to
unlock that I just don't have yet so but
I thought that I would try to chat
suggestions so that at the very least
you don't get to man watching it okay I
think we need to go up that's what we
need to do I don't want to use my spirit
shot day I guess I have to
Hey oh I can use you to do that yeah
yeah give me more of that go again that
was very helpful please please come on
yeah do it oh my god I've never wanted
someone to shoot me so badly in my life
come on buddy okay no just just I'm just
trying to get you to shoot upwards where
did it come from
that would help me tremendously sir come
on yeah do it do it do it do it my Tommy
what's wrong
oh no beautiful thank you love that from
you okay I don't remember with whether
the wall is I think it's pretty far
across all the way over there oh this is
gonna suck without these shots man it's
really gonna suck come on come on what
give me it give me it that's no idea I
enough to make that come on I'm just
hanging out here waiting to be killed
with a projectile wouldn't that be a
nice time for me somebody above just
shot one now who has done that wherever
you are I would like to see more weight
to the bubbles just where did you just
come from I could have used you a long
time ago well [ __ ] what did it how do I
need to do this whole time okay that's
it we just gotta wait for that then oh
that one that's good too how we should
use both probably shitty use but you can
get me up this way I've worked the whole
plumber
let's try buff that's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna let him shoot me so that I get
into the air and then wait for the
bubble no high up that's another one
okay come on just we need one more thing
it was looking good it was looking good
yep come on come on one more come on
mmm
come on buddy don't go to sleep on me
now what happened to him
where did my son go I needed your help
what is happening underwater here I feel
like things are just changing in front
of my eyes you cannot ride the air
bubbles you can only bounce off of them
he's back he's back come on well that
was not how that was supposed to go
right up here oh so close that
keep breaking it come on somebody else
it's fine
all right give me one so I can jump
across so I can then use the bubble
she's gonna go again I wish that I could
figure out who's shooting them over to
the left because that's handy like if
you could shoot me right now whoever you
are mysterious stranger I would love
that
I would love I would like to see it I
would like to see it but I don't no way
you all yeah not again not again
god damn spikes
yeah I get that top dude to shoot me
come on come on but no no bites just
shoots the bubbles disappeared again
what is happening in this ecosystem
where has bubble gone I'm very confused
I'm sure I can get an underwater - and
looma pool friend I can't get it now
I guess shot something I don't know what
a shot
I shot something that emits bubbles you
think oh it's that it's just that right
there that's it okay
hey bud you need to give me and then we
just got a gret yeah that's right that's
right
that should shoot it and then the bubble
should come up great
again bobble why don't you grab it
some of a [ __ ] breaking those bubbles
when that happens is devastating both
would be such a good Hey
stay in your lane sir projectiles only
please what is the other guy
come on come back [ __ ] okay uh maybe
they just break after her 7-point excuse
me
accidentally he'll come back he'll be
back now he is back okay I'm gonna try
and go from this way again anyway I
think this might work now nope so my
thought is that I could do that and then
land on a bubble but that didn't quite
work out it's not high enough
we need more height we need more height
whoever's shooting me from the top I
want you I want you so bad I just I just
want to see it
if I could just see where he was you
know that's it
that is my own fault I just keep jumping
too high it's buried um come on come on
just a little tiny bit low it's just
that's it it's my it's on it's on it's
on me it's absolutely on me do we have
to burst this again no it's okay all
right but let's go come on
do you ting Thank You bubble time or if
the tough guy could shoot something at
me that's my bad I would love that
I would just make my day again
bubble time
why didn't you grab it but that one was
I think your fault actually died so
well-animated did I kill the bubble
machine I didn't okay
[ __ ] hell it's somehow getting worse
[Music]
it's probably not the right thing to do
I wish that I could just get this to
[ __ ] hit me from the bottom I can
grab it cuz I have done it I grabbed it
from the other side my logic is that I
could just grab it from this side again
because I have done it once before um I
still want to know where that top
[ __ ] is cuz he he'd be helping
me tons hey why do you push it away just
bounce them's the rules just bounce
okay maybe I can't grab it like I fast
we got this one I did it one time and
that's what I'm I'm clung to here we
know we can do this all right
we know those bubbles go up and we need
to jump on one of them so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna jump off this
and then jump onto a bubble that's the
plan
jumping off of things it's not that easy
though because you can't just like hit B
and drop you have to jump off which is
very weird so because you see jumps up I
have to jump away and then probably
about now boom too late but that's what
I'm gonna try that's what I think the
plan is I think the fact that I've been
manipulating that ground monster is a
unique experience to me that is not what
his intended purposes are I'm gonna go
right now
though I just didn't - then I think
that'll probably do it actually grab
that jump off [ __ ] just missed it I
think this is gonna work you think yes I
always forget that those don't glow blue
because there are like two separate it's
what I'll Anton type things that you can
attach to always like I hit I'll be when
it glows blue and they actually don't
all right go now okay Oh
still didn't work still not enough you
need to get higher I need more height I
can only grab where it's uh I know I can
grab anything I can grab a reset on pink
it is very complicated
this game is complicated that is not
it's it's simple and complicated and at
the same time I'm in a weird way
yeah I don't know how to describe that
but it totally is that's it that's it we
[ __ ] did it and that's the I was
about said see what the jerk
he was probably throwing [ __ ] at me all
right thank you thank you I did waste a
lot of time trying me underwater method
that might be the longest I've ever
wasted on a puzzle
well that was bad but you know sometimes
you got to get creative to figure this
stuff out which is the thing that I
really like about this game I also don't
ever really find it frustrating it's
very good
it is not a frustrating experience I'm
gonna do that with one of these no I
have to shoot it order than that okay
from about y'all she's gonna go up and
kill it isn't it nope haha mine son oh
that's gonna be a toilet open
I shouldn't sound so pleased this is
actually gonna be a huge bummer oh so
close I'm going to the bathroom I'll be
right back let me just mute my
microphone
I realize I muted myself I'm gonna leave
the the game on so you can listen to the
beautiful music
[Music]
[Music]
well they didn't kill me they just sit
in that chillin having a good time
excuse me while I fold my legs because I
can never sit like a normal person okay
plan here we are once again asking for
your donations I'm not actually I never
asked for donations it was just a pony
Santos reference oh that's right there
that's super easy get dead yet dead good
day sir
it's nice knowing you okay that's gonna
be a whoop so what's gonna happen here
is it's gonna be a door that this game
wants me to open a door which I am oh so
close
presently not seeing there it is okay
got it
well what is that one what do you do
okay
I will activate the pedestal thank you
[Music]
speedrun
those a little um like speedrun
challenges all most of them are at least
I really stuck to to that that's cool
okay
should be able to grab this wall this
one's gonna be another one of these I
think don't hit anything you're my only
hope
[ __ ] that's gone oh we can grab this
anyway okay
yes uh um I know that I can keep going
up to get through that but I kind of
want to so what the door is oh there's
another one down here so that's why
we're gonna go we're gonna go underwater
get the thing hey bud
what can I use you for you probably have
a purpose I just don't know what your
purpose is Oh fling me up that's your
purpose got it okay I used you
incorrectly and I apologize try again
come back come back okay you're gonna
rock up me into the air it's gonna be a
great time for everyone I hurt myself
but I made it work and I think I'm gonna
use you to break the bubble also if you
would do that for me would be great
other way other way other way there we
go nice nice nice
okay ouch all right
oh that moved a lot more than I expected
it to [ __ ] [ __ ] what happened I'm
just trying to shoot my arrows I can't
okay it's moving so that I can do that
that's nice of you thank you all right
we gotta get up I haven't a mother and I
I do yeah I'm good
let me get that help first Oh
she is mate let's see if there's
anything else at the top that I can do
you and of course there is I don't know
why I'm opening this Keystone right now
it seems like the wrong direction but
you're there for a reason you want the
game music up sure I just didn't want it
to be too loud I thought about dyeing my
hair a different color I've had my hair
many colors oh hey I love a good tree
but I'm keeping this one for now
have fun wasted bandwidth there it is
there she is
this is just a standard ability or do I
need to equip it swim - it's just gonna
be a standard ability you'll love to see
it there's so much that I didn't do
though I just like having everything
uncovered you know
fine oh I can out - out of water -
that's pretty sick
and break things I've become so
independent I'm my own man Fox thing
usually I can land on the tree I guess I
don't need to do that anyway okay come
on let's go where is it that we need to
drop down well let's try a first swim
against the current well let's do it
come on no come on seriously one of my
favorite things about this game is how
much you just beat the living hell out
of Ari he takes up beating and sometimes
it's like it's just beneficial for you
to take damage so you just you just do
it little guy just has to take the L I
will be needing that thank you thank you
thank you thank you
I don't need to go up but I'm gonna need
you do you want that though that would
be tight did this guy just kill himself
does this man just show up and kill
himself that's devastating all right let
me get up there don't explode thank you
whoo I love Wall
this game is chock full of crap it's
true yeah it's uh it's very full good
value for money I think super bummer
about the framerate issues it's uh I
really do want to iterate that um I have
have not had those experiences before
this stream I mean I I have had
framerate drops I said that it stopped
but not not anywhere near as bad as they
are right now oh where did they all go
okay
out
yeah it looks like it's underwater but
it not hey I was rude no and then I do
it again I'm trying to try to steal it
the direct dial me bro oh that's not
what I wanted not what I wanted at all
yeah I need I need you Be Named thank
you
[ __ ] didn't expect you to catch up okay
try me again come on come on come on
let's go you need to be high up just a
little bit higher
get out of my way he killed me very rude
you can just duck you I don't need you
mosquito get out I do need the feeder
like not desperately but if he died it
would be above me [ __ ] okay I guess
we're doing that for some reason okay
cool I'll take it ah yeah the frame
rates all better now that I'm not in the
water that like I said I think it's a
water issue
it's probably just very difficult for
the UM the engine to manage all them
physics yep it happens all right okay
you two are done for oops oops hey what
the bubbles go there we go yes please
nope yes please yes please okay thank
you thank you I will take it more energy
it's a good time um have you done this
whole area this whole room
I have feels good man oh so now we go
back down and this this like I feel like
I should mention that this entire room
was just for bonus content this whole
thing was
none of that impacted the story no don't
not the spikes not sorry come on now if
you had some kind of spirit could you
just be slightly less squishy okay
if there was something here I would see
it there is not you got any collectibles
down here for me though why are you
following me what do I need you for
I cannot see a reason why this is just
some kind of trap some kind of sadistic
trap
my guess I just need to open it again
seems weird don't know why you would
play me like that am I gonna need what
if I throw this up here is just gonna
fall in come on there we go just don't
know that's it's very unusual with it oh
maybe I needed to get him out of here
Wow look how hot he went is this
something here that's breakable no very
strange what did I miss
thank you dude where's the pizza on a
scale of 1 to 10 how hyped at MIFA deme
um I'm I'm very excited to play dude I
think it's gonna be a great time I love
those games yes I have nothing negative
to say about virtually anything in the
doom franchise it is all very good stuff
okay
is this where we had our stompy stops I
don't think so right this doesn't look
right
no it's further back but there is an
entrance to something here I can't get
for that okay okay okay
[Music]
oh yeah I forgot that I can fling myself
at a woman you just learn how to do that
and you already forgot your big dummy
okay I think it's here right
it still seems wrong no that does seem
right okay big jokes can you not not
right now I don't have time oh so easy I
got a bit rushed FET
I can't believe they ever had trouble
with that let it be known that despite
from the very beginning telling the chat
that I did not think it was possible I
still tried anyway just to show you it's
not possible good I'll take those
actually
not today Squidward
okay
why is this happened
oh that's a Chuck it just doesn't like
water oh my god it's bad re oh this is
such a good game it's so heartbreaking
than it has performance issues that are
this bad it also updated yesterday which
means it was a that was a patch
it's very pretty Tyler it's very pretty
no worries Goodman gaming I did no
horizon zero dawn it's coming to PC I've
known it for a while actually and I know
I think it's good for everyone
whoa I didn't press that button you just
crash me - it's crashing me - the menu
or is that just because I'm pressing why
I didn't press Y if I all decks it just
saves Y would walk me but I don't think
I did maybe that muster
unless that is some kind of defense
mechanism business I don't know all
right
that's and we can't [ __ ] with that let's
go let's go that's good
yeesh that water go spooky okay where am
I trying to go though
hello tiny friend
oh is that the logic Tuttle I believe it
says you told me to hurry and look for
him but I don't know where he is oh
there he is what haven't you so what's
wrong with your face
you okay bud
I am a concern in peace if it's games
like this lobby music music first bar
you're not wrong oh you gave me another
wisp they made my boy evil
why have you done that I liked him why
do you have to be so mean to
oh boy oh you're being controlled by the
water wants to we've met before
we have met before that's this is [ __ ]
up Jesus no chill okay let's go bud
thank you for breaking that I appreciate
it
so these chase sequences were also in
the first game and are just oh that's
where I die very intense but when you're
having framerate problems
yikes that's right about that that's
might be this might be in theory that
shouldn't have killed me I was just
chilling in the water it's your own
fault
really yeah the thing I find kind of
cool about these sequences at you is
that you have to figure out why you're
going before you can even see where it's
supposed to go it's like you're always
gonna have to do the more than once
because things will kill you without you
even knowing that they are going to kill
you at any point that makes sense oh oh
damn gotta be real quick there okay yeah
it's just a lot of um anticipation based
on the level design all my screwed that
one up
that was rude keeps doing it it's very
inconsiderate
down down uh uh re come on we don't have
time for this get out of there I don't
even know what happened there can I get
just stuck to it accidentally
[Music]
okay
don't get punched in the face by that
stupid thing ha ha suckaaaa not today
not this time
Oh No jump up for that one
you keep running keep running yeah I'll
take that
keep running okay oh it's a fight
interesting interesting
okay I don't know how to damage you
oh well easily apparently that's not bad
it's not that bad
that's checked out we're gonna store
that right back oh by the way throw that
right back at [ __ ] or those that's why
it gave me the spirit shots that makes
sense
can you to shoot more bombs at me please
that would be tight
this is suspicious
why have you done this what oh I lost
where I was I could apply myself okay I
want to get you tongue out of it really
can't send that back out what
just more explosives please there we go
boom Oh what happening we do it we done
did it oh look at that rare achievement
oh cool I don't want a quest
get out of here game boss I don't have
time for that
why'd you live in an F we did it we did
it yeah look I like the Frog okay that's
the thing I'm a fan of the Frog but when
the Frog starts being a jerk I'm gonna
take him out
I'm I have to I might have to take him
out okay and I feel like when the Frog
is back to being his regular Frog self
and Ari has a nice man-to-man with him
and his leg listen I have to
everything's gonna be all G they'll be
no problems between the lads
hey but did you do it you killed the
water demon I couldn't do it I'm proud
of you
damn you look so sad he looks like me
and my emo phase when I was about 15
that's what we like to hear
[Music]
okay for you I will do that I will find
the wisps and the mochi I didn't do that
to him off oh that wasn't me Ella Wolfie
what's up welcome no joke I do like a
good chap stick I'll be honest
oh my god
why does everyone I love have to die
that's a huge bummer Wow I really liked
him
cool yeah strength to the forest you
make it like a celebration a man died
okay thank you again I appreciate that
appreciate the rare achievement
yeah good cry now maybe
I don't well it's fine you know [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] but hoes and tricks is what I
always say so you know lesson one just
so sad though Jesus no okay yeah I'm
just having a real potty down here now
is that what's happened you guys don't
even care that the lodge turtle died
inconsiderate okay the music's really
sad male 200 my heart I don't have time
for you I don't want to I don't want to
be doing this right now man you can die
but the underwater ones can just go away
that would suit my schedule wonderfully
if they would just leave me alone and
also make sure I have all the
collectibles I do need to get down there
but how
it's right there you see it it's right
there yeah there's another way
maybe that loops back around or
something nothing else seems to mm-hmm
interesting hmm no my friend just died I
don't want to play with you I'm glad I
just hit you by accident just so you
know all of you take all the hits see
how much I care so hoping this would go
backwards so I could get that
collectible but it ain't which means I'm
probably gonna lose out on some of this
what's this oh I can't get through the
sand just yet which is Obama
but not yet I'll be back for you and I'm
annoyed about this little connection
we're missing we can't do that yet
either we got pretty much everything
this is up here this area I think I got
all the underwater stuff today so it's a
big game man
this is an area I never went to cuz it's
all underwater and it's before I could
swim all righty
to you then where's the closest shrine
yeah let's go out we go
ah
thank you Ozzy rampage you're right no
one has ever really dead uncle bag
buglar time you're right
that's a really interesting point a
night light yeah I don't even feel
comfortable calling this game a 2-d game
I don't know why but that just doesn't
seem like the right thumb for this game
for some reason to me because I mean it
is it literally is but something about
it just seems so it just has so much
depth that I don't know it just seems
false to call it that for some reason
okay one you got an in peace um I wanted
to go to my spirit shots see if there is
anything I like better than what I have
right now reckless nut donut resilience
yeah that would be handy but no it's
that ultra mash do I just have regular
bash right now I have it equipped magnet
is handy but I don't need it no what
good everything's fine
I would like to find a salesman of some
kind though I have things to buy I just
gone straight across as a breakable
floor here apparently
it's not that little bit further
oh thanks whoo that's right I forgot
about that great Oh brilliant Chuck you
near the breakable fool it's right here
huh
if it is I don't see it I like I believe
you Matt but I can't see it you know you
tell me where I'm going
just look around what is this Alex I
quit okay it's fine
hey Thank You Joshua reshoot that do I
have to hit everyone okay this is why my
other friend died
stupid depressing game
yeah that's the thing I'm just gonna
keep keep moving past that that spoiler
oh I guess I have to go back to the tree
well enjoy the spoiler it's right here
if you don't want to see it go away but
again this isn't really a um a game
about the story in any case I don't
think what is happening to the frames
also where are you telling me to go just
to this tree yeah I think that's wrong
actually I have to find the wisps that's
I should not have come here this was the
wrong hole are you gonna give me a wisp
yes so where we actually want to go is
down here let's do that if we can break
through that floor
ah damn beautiful game so sad so frame
ready
um then I don't recall where I'm going
it's just down through the floor all
right cool I already broke that floor we
good and then I look at the map a lot
sorry about that
all the way down across I try to go down
there got it need your help
thank you All Right see ya appreciate
that you exited there very helpful hmm
well thank you Joshua
am I ever gonna put much out again I
don't know um that first lot of much was
you know as you know for charity company
reached out to me and asked if I wanted
to sell much I said sure I'll do if
charity I don't know about any other
point in time I might it's not something
I'm like actively working on also just
feels weird to me I don't know I feel
like a lot of people follow me because
they're interested in my career not
because they're necessarily interested
in me as a person so selling much just
feels like a strange thing to do so cool
okay should I quit my flames then the
darkness skitters invites great can't
wait
looking forward to that giant spider
it's gonna make me fight let's get my
point okay I didn't realize that was
this bike my pad my bad
I just want to get this here we go okay
we got it got it got it
no you don't know you don't hey that's
mean I'm just trying to float pause
please leave me alone
I have no quarrel with you
oh [ __ ] that's not floating anymore oh
these guys suck
no you're garbage you need to die ish
hit yourself stop hitting yourself stop
hitting yourself stop hitting yourself
he didn't really even hit himself that
much no I do need those honestly it's
been a very long time since I found
someone I can buy stuff off both dead
done okay cool just gonna fling me
upwards feel like it might it looks like
there are secrets in there I can get to
it that totally looks like there's some
way to go up I'm wrong there is someone
to go up here though
where's that right there let's take a
look shall we
wrong ability that bomb is cool though I
wasn't LT that's what
you know it's it is this room right
right yeah don't hit anything
thank you
appreciate that okay what are you what
the hell has happened here YouTube chat
oh okay I'm very confused about what's
happened here
oh when I said I don't think fans are
that interested in me as person I didn't
like meet it that way that's not a it's
not like I'm not I'm not trying to do it
as a young people don't like me type
situation it's just like that's not how
I think I got my following because I'm
not like super high energetic person or
whatever it's it's just because I've
been because my career mostly Wyant why
aren't I playing cod with Bruce because
I want to play re man it's very pretty
you see something spider in the
background yeah this place is special
I'm gonna be full of spiders and it's
gonna suck because I hate spiders do I
have a console I have all of them yes
okay maybe they don't miss deeper and
more dangerous great love it can't wait
to see how that goes for me okay
oh well I thought that was gonna be
something that would give me money or
whatever it was not
okay it's definitely yeah you know what
it actually annoys me as a person who
hates spiders
well I'm supposed to follow the bug I
see I see why does every game
God I have spied a level seems a bit
unnecessary what if you had anything
else okay I guess we looped that cave
interesting though it's a very cool way
to I could have gone further and down
how do you keep coming back stay dead
wait so hmm it's the control of start to
vibrate when I stay in the dock for too
long
so I'm guessing it is as dangerous as it
say it is each it's gonna be a [ __ ]
yeah that's a dead bug what are you just
a pretty leaf of some kind get away from
me oh this levels gonna be tough man
because it it's so like
the controller stops vibrating so
quickly it just feels very oppressive
trying to even traverse if that makes
sense
I think the darkness killed me oh yeah
this is some real [ __ ] it's gonna be
happening here why have I done that
though do they maybe help me as well as
any of my abilities help me know if we
just want to blaze in theory should help
me no darkness killed me damn damn rough
now why should I race with charity I
will actually be posting a screenshot of
the donation as soon as I get it so that
should be in the next few days you
talking about Joe Rogan in that what is
happening I don't know where these
conversations are all coming from god
damn I don't think that I have the
mental capacity to continue torturing
myself with the stream there ladies
gentlemen but hey everyone we had 25,000
subscribers followers rather definitely
not subscribe as as I do and I have that
option enabled on Twitch thank you for
following that's very cool
I appreciate that that's uh what's a
cool little milestone to get there so
thank you
and I don't know when I mix it right now
I don't think it's very many good makes
it's like like Milan with a little tiny
make see community I like it though
I mean rashes all gone Jake Fleur they
want rashes it's skin peeling and no but
pretty close it's almost gone
naturally when I spoke about having like
a skin issue I got so many people being
like trying to scream try the scream but
yeah I didn't I didn't talk about it
publicly until the doctor had already
diagnosed me and like given me a cream
to you so I was already on top of that
and it's been really helpful whatever it
is actually don't know it was just like
I will take it if you say it will work
so so I have been eczema is annoying
Thank You Kenneth it's been really cool
seeing people's photos it's it's been
awesome Thank You Pete Cahill won 9-8 I
am planning to yeah steampunk assassin
also related I am planning to start
streaming once a week see if I can pull
it off I try not to like overdo myself
but yeah straight Fox I am 26 but yes I
plan to try and stream once a week
probably Wednesdays is a good day to do
it she's doing Wednesday's but we'll see
if I can if I can do it I intend to
that's the plan have faith in me
and yeah the game is now playable I
think it has been for an hour so
everyone can play it I'm about six hours
in at this point and it is beautiful and
I highly recommend it huge bummer about
the framerate drops during the stream
but it happens it sucks but it happens
I hope they fix it though because aside
from that I have just virtually no
complaints about this game it's so good
so thick below all right I might put up
a what's been like two months since my
last stream it's been like two weeks
since my lost dreams I'm just gonna hide
you from my channel anyway so you just
post a negative stuff over and over and
over again goodbye
no one's gonna see your comments anymore
you think I walked through this for the
east Jamie you're kidding I'm not good
at platformers at all that's a nightmare
for me well I got the rare achievement
in combat I never said I was bad at
combat frankly I'm good at combat in
most games but platforming is a whole
other thing I don't even want to know
how many times I've died in this sofa
Zayn Nath I'm playing off of Xbox which
is what Xbox recommended to me or told
me to do frankly when they email me the
code I do lift weights Jason thank you
for noticing
monarch well I did download the patch
today so this is with the patch
hopefully it's patched again because
it's such a bummer and it does it does
hurt a game like this which flows so
well and it's so fast-paced when the
frame rate cuts down so yeah big bummer
thank you joke I appreciate that thank
you is enough it's I'm gonna finish it
regardless but it'll be good to see
thank you Ray
my favorite game at the moment steampunk
assassin it would be this game it's very
good
dag fan Lindholm said stop talking about
do metal more please I think you're
telling me to talk about do metal mall I
will have a doom eternal gameplay up on
my channel probably tomorrow ideally
all right I think I'm gonna head off
have a good night thank you for joining
me everyone my